what's up guys my name is China welcome
back to my Ray tracing series last
episode if you didn't catch it we did
some pretty cool stuff including
bouncing some rays around to create
Reflections today we're going to have a
simple but very important episode and
we're going to be talking about
materials and how we can create a
material system for our Ray tracing
application so first of all what is a
material and why materials so important
I feel like most the time when we think
of a ray Tracer or any kind of rendering
we focus a lot on the light because
light is obviously extremely important
without light there wouldn't really be
anything to see and there certainly
wouldn't be anything for us to render
but this might be a little bit
controversial but materials are possibly
even more important than light I mean I
guess I can't kind of say that materials
are necessarily more important than
light but they are more complicated than
light light is really straightforward
like really straightforward light just
comes from a source and hits stuff
that's its job that's it that's all
being a light source is easy have you
tried being a light source I guess I
can't say I have but it's easy trust me
because as a light source you just kind
of
exist like you're just there light just
flows from you energy just flows from
you and it hits stuff that that's all
you need to do as a light just provide
some some energy the complexity of
rendering and Ray tracing comes from
materials it comes from a surface
because what happens once the light hits
the surface yeah
that is the complicated part today I'm
using a screwdriver not a pen so if we
send out some light from a light source
and it comes and it hits this desk in
front of us what happens to the light
where does it go next how much energy
does it bounce off how much energy does
it absorb all of this kind of
information about a surface and how it
transmits light and effectively what
color reaches the final Observer which
in our case is kind of a pixel remember
when we're Ray tracing kind of do it in
reverse we start from the camera and we
send Rays out from the camera instead of
sending them out from arbitrary light
sources and then hoping some of them hit
the camera because that would be very
very performance intensive and not
optimal but all of this detail about how
light actually behaves once it hits
something that is a complex topic and
that is where materials come in because
materials are a way for us to Define
these surface properties that will
Define and shape how that light actually
behaves because believe it or not the
ray tracing that we've done thus far
that's kind of all there is to it in a
way we'll expand on that later the
reason why these spheres here might not
look exactly photorealistic to you isn't
because of the way that we're shooting
Rays it's not that we need to shoot Rays
differently it's not that we need to set
up our camera differently what it
actually is is tied directly into the
material properties of this sphere and
how they actually transmit and scatter
light and that comes down to materials
which is what we're going to start
talking about here today but you know
what's super important to know as we
embark on this complicated journey of
materials and surfaces math but how do I
learn math in a good exciting engaging
way why what do you know I have just the
thing for you brilliant the sponsor of
this video and this entire Ray tracing
series brilliant is an amazing website
filled with plenty of courses on various
stem topics they've got plenty of
courses on computer science and regular
science but I particularly love their
math courses and think they're an
amazing fit for this series whether
you're a beginner and just starting your
math Journey or you're quite Advanced
and just want to go deep into the mouth
behind Ray tracing they have it all and
the thing that sets brilliant apart from
other websites is just how incredibly
Visual and engaging their courses
actually are their lessons are filled
with all these amazing widgets you can
play with so that you deeper understand
the concepts that you're actually
learning you'll get quiz on all of these
topics to make sure you're retaining the
information and you can even do all of
this on your phone on the go the best
thing about brilliant is you can get
started absolutely for free just go to
brilliant.org the channel and see how
you like it if you do like it brilliant
have been nice enough to offer the first
200 of my subscribers 20 off an annual
membership so hurry up and check that
out it's a really great way to commit
yourself to learning about all of the
math that goes into this series and make
sure that you actually understand it
huge thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring this video okay so let's talk
about materials and we're gonna take a
bit of a practical approach with today's
episode what I kind of want to do is I
want to set up one of these spheres as
like a floor now you might think that we
need like a box or like a plane or
something so that we we have a flaw but
really what we can do is we can just
move this blue Sphere for example to the
origin
make the radius like a hundred and then
simply just lower it like on the y-axis
until we see it which will be right
about
101.4 the radius of this is 0.5 if we
just lift that up to one then we can
just set this to be minus 101 I think
and that should be basically exactly on
the floor now I'm going to remember
these values so 1 and then minus 101 100
so that I can just make it like start up
like that we can't really save scenes
that would probably be a nice feature to
have but for now we don't really need
that I'm just going to go ahead and make
this radius one and then over here let's
make this a hundred minus 101 and this
will become zero
okay just double check that that's all
working okay cool so now we have this
kind of floor plane what I actually
might do if we hop into our camera class
for a second I might just back it up a
bit more this is effectively I mean I
could have just made this fears smaller
or whatever but I think our radius of
one is going to be fine okay cool so
let's talk about why these spheres
appear the way they do and why they are
reflective in the first place so we have
the ability to set a color for these
spheres that's something that we set up
in the previous episode or whatever but
how does this work exactly and should it
should it be in the place that it's at
and the answer to that is not really and
the way that works is inside the scene
class or inside the scene.h file we have
a sphere and we have this Albedo
variable over here which controls the
color of the sphere now it's set to
White by default but inside our example
layout we do set this one to be pink and
this one to be blue now as we talked
about Albedo is kind of like the non-lit
color of our surface but what about how
reflective the surface is how does that
work and also don't different materials
reflect light differently like a shiny
metal looks very different to say wood
or concrete or some kind of plastic how
can we represent all of these surfaces
in a nice little neat package of
parameters and more importantly how do
we do this in a way that is more or less
standardized because we are just writing
code at the end of the day and since we
are the programmers we could Define any
number of mathematical equations and
parameters that can be used to kind of
mutate and modify the way that our light
transport works but if everyone did that
if everyone just implemented all of this
stuff in their own way wouldn't there
just be a huge mess and the answer is
yeah there would be a huge mess in fact
there was for a long time until we
developed a standard called physically
based rendering this book over here
physically based rendering from Theory
to implementation I talked about this in
very first episode of this series that's
a fantastic resource for this if you
want more details I'm not going to make
this video All About physically based
rendering it's a very complicated topic
but just know that it's effectively a
way for us to standardize parameters
that we can use to represent any
material that exists in the real world
hence the name physically based because
it's based on physics it's based on like
the real world and taking light
measurements of how materials actually
behave like existing materials like wood
and metal and plastic and different
types of metals how all of that actually
behaves in the real world developing a
series of parameters such as like Albedo
roughness metalness metallic whatever
you want to call it all these different
things to kind of be able to represent
these materials in a standard way now as
a side note there is more than one kind
of way to implement physically based
rendering so it's not quite as black and
white as just there's just one way and
that's it but it is pretty much the
standard for all renderers these days
like everything from games so unity and
Unreal Engine how their render work to
offline CGI Graphics using like blender
or Maya or whatever else physically
based rendering is basically the way
that modern renderers work and that's
also the kind of renderer we will be
building here as well now at its core
yes physically based rendering is a
series of algorithms and equations it's
a bunch of math that we do to simulate
how light works that's why I keep
talking about brilliant as well it's you
need to know your map but the other way
you could look at physically based
rendering is not caring about the
equations and the kind of math behind
the scenes that actually makes it work
but just thinking about the input
parameters that we can use to define
different materials and the core of
those are effectively like a surface
color which we call Albedo a roughness
or a glossiness which is basically how
smooth a surface is how polished it is
versus how rough it might be and also a
metallic value so is it a metal or is it
a dielectric which is a non-conductive
material like wood like concrete like
those three parameters
are basically all we need now of course
those values don't have to be constant
across the surface that's where textures
and maps come in but for any given Ray
that hits a surface we need to be able
to describe what is the Albedo color of
that particular hit there what is the
roughness value and what is the metallic
value and again keeping things practical
here that's what we kind of need to add
we need to have a metallic and a
roughness value here now at this point
we're getting a little bit heavy here so
what I'm going to do instead is make a
new struct called material and then all
of the material properties we're going
to put into here and I'm simply going to
have a material inside this sphere now
this is not a very good way of doing
this but I just want to show it this way
first just so that everyone's on the
same page of what's really going on here
without complicating it too much so
we've got Albedo we've got roughness and
I'm also going to put in a metallic
value here of just zero we're not going
to worry about modeling this just yet
but this will be useful for the future
and then for a darkness and when I have
a default of one which just means that
it shouldn't really be very reflective
at all not a smooth surface so now that
we have this here let's go back to
Walnut app and fix up all of our errors
so this is now going to be just the
materials Albedo for both of our spheres
here if we scroll down a bit we'll have
to make sure that we can actually
manipulate the Albedo here let's also
add in roughness and metallic and these
are just floats so we can get rid of
this value pointer
and make sure they're not color edits
but rather
and drag flirt and then if we go back to
our renderer we'll also have to fix up
the errors that we have over here so the
sphere Albedo will now get from the
actual material and let's just hit F5 to
make sure everything's still working and
yep everything looks good and you can
see we now have a roughness and a
metallic value that we can actually
control here so how exactly does
roughness work and what does it really
mean well without getting too deep into
it because I want to save that for a
separate kind of physically based
rendering series of videos when our
array comes in and hits our surface
every surface that you have is made up
of this thing called a micro facet which
is basically to say that surfaces might
look level and smooth but in reality if
you zoom in like with a microscope
they're not going to be like a straight
line they'll be Jagged and this degree
of jaggedness so in other words how
rough is that actual material at that
kind of micro facet level that will
determine which way light will travel so
if we were to have a perfectly smooth
plane then what would happen is the
light would come in from this light here
it would hit our surface and it would
perfectly reflect along the normal which
is exactly what we're actually doing
over here in the code right we're
setting the the ray direction of our
next bounce to be a perfect reflection
of the direction along the actual World
normal the vector perpendicular to the
surface that we've hit now in reality
though nothing is probably that smooth I
mean a mirror is probably a good example
of something that is very very smooth so
that would kind of have a roughness of
zero not that that's physically possible
but let's just assume it is but as we
get rougher and rougher as we get to
something more like this wooden table
which first of all isn't a metal so the
image that we actually see is going to
be a bit different but let's not talk
about metals and dielectrics and that
stuff just yet if this was to be rougher
and that kind of microfacet was more
Jagged then instead of just reflecting
this light along the normal and then
that bounce being perfectly reflected
well it might not go exactly that way it
might go this way it might go that way
it might go back a little bit that way
when that light comes in it kind of gets
scattered and the degree to which it
gets scattered so in other words does it
get scattered kind of in this area
anywhere inside this area or is it just
wild and could go in random directions
that is determined by the degree of that
jaggedness the degree of the roughness
so in other words what I'm saying is
that if you had a roughness of zero a
perfectly smooth surface then you would
kind of see like a mirror reflection
because every Ray that comes from here
gets reflected perfectly like Camaro
would but as you begin to turn up the
roughness as it becomes more and more
Jagged that reflection gets blurrier and
blurrier it gets less well defined
because the rays are becoming more and
more scattered this is just supposed to
be an introductory explanation I'm going
to get much deeper into this with
diagrams and all that stuff in the
future this is a bit of a gentle
introduction but I'm also deliberately
not using too many diagrams here because
I want you to imagine this for yourself
maybe even draw this on a piece of paper
and think about how it could work that's
a much more powerful way to learn and
retain its information than just me
showing you everything straight away so
knowing what we know at the moment let's
see if we can kind of mutate or modify
the degree of this reflection based on
the roughness so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to look at this reflection
over here and what I kind of want to do
here is I want to like shift this
direction a little bit based on how
rough the surface is so the rougher the
surface is the more I shift this
direction and then the smoother it I do
that let's all the way down to it being
perfectly along the world normal there's
a few different ways you could do this
you could just offset it by just adding
a vector here what I'm going to do
though is I'm just going to take this
world normal which is what we reflected
against and I'm going to add an offset
to it so what I want to do is just write
plus sphere dot material dot roughness
let's just drop this down a little bit
times some kind of range so for now I'll
just write walnuts random vect3 and I
don't know I'll just write negative 0.5
positive 0.5 so what I've done here is
I've basically offset this world normal
by a random vect3 between negative 0.5
and positive 0.5 and then I've taken
that offset Vector so this is the
maximum like range it's allowed to be
I'm multiplying that by the roughness so
you can see that if the roughness was
Zero if it was perfectly smooth then
this would be zero times that Vector
which means that I'm not doing any of
this right but if the roughness is one
then it's taking in that full Randomness
now why use random here well because I
mean that's how Services work at that
kind of micro facet level we can't like
you're not going to manually define the
properties of the surface it's just the
way that it is and we need a way to kind
of send that bouncing Ray in some random
Direction now this is where noise is
gonna come into the equation here
because now that we're not perfectly
reflecting our vectors here our Rays
we're going to wind up in a situation
where every frame really is going to
look a little bit random since the
actual specific direction we reflect in
is going to be different frame to frame
now this kind of goes really well into
path tracing and accumulation and like
the sample count so how many of these
Rays we actually shoot out from that
from that initial intersection and don't
you worry all of that stuff is right
around the corner so this is basically
what I'm gonna leave it at for now let's
go ahead and hit F5 and we're going to
run this and see what happens okay cool
so what do I see here I see a very kind
of noisy model here something that
almost looks like some analog TV or
something let's go ahead and adjust the
roughness though I'm going to set the
roughness of this pink sphere here to be
zero Okay cool so now I see like a
perfect image of this this still looks a
little bit weird let's go ahead and set
the blue flaws roughness to zero and you
can see I see a perfect image now what
happens if I try and increase some of
this now the the rate at which is
increasing is too much but if I set it
to 0.1 look at that
doesn't that kind of make sense it's
like we're seeing a rough version of the
sphere there I mean I could even try and
lower it even more
and you can see that as I kind of play
with the roughness here let's also set
this to like point one I'm seeing like a
rougher version of that reflection now
at the moment I am just sending one
sample per array so what I'm doing is
that Ray that's being reflected I'm just
sending a single right that's obviously
not how light works light is just like
this flood of like photons and all this
other stuff that's coming in and it's
going to get reflected like there's
going to be almost an infinite amount of
particles you could think of it that way
particles coming in from the light
bounce off here they scatter everywhere
we basically need to do this a lot more
than just once and by doing that we'll
get a much more accurate image and we
won't see any of this noise that's of
course a lot more performance intensive
but we will get into that a little bit
later in this series as well and as I
mentioned that is where path tracing
comes in but for now you can kind of see
what that looks like now one major
problem here is that our Skybox our kind
of background I guess is just black and
that's not really going to look that
great here because if you look at what's
going on as we bounce around here we
eventually hit the sky and the sky is
just black and so we don't like we just
terminate what we should do is
incorporate the sky color there that's
going to be really cool because it's
going to kind of allow us to actually
occlude that ambient light and ambient
occlusion as you might know is very very
important for realistic rendering so
what we can do is just Define a
different Sky color I might go for 0.6
0.7 and 0.9 so we kind of have like a
nice bright washed out blue alright and
check this out suddenly this looks a lot
more interesting let's go ahead and
lower the roughness to like point one
actually let's keep this fear like
perfectly reflective and then we'll
lower the roughness of our floor to 0.1
okay and as you can see we're getting a
little bit of that occlusion there now
the reason why we're not getting too
much occlusion is because this
multiplier is a little high let's remove
it a little bit you can see that we can
kind of see like a shadow like some kind
of occlusion of ambient light going on
right here in the Middle where where
this sphere is and if I just drag the
sphere up it kind of goes away right
because what's happening is we're
bouncing light off of this blue kind of
floor sphere and it's not getting to our
Skylight and in fact you can up the
amount of bounces here to like five or I
don't know 50 would probably be fine and
you can begin to see that we have like
this nice kind of image of occlusion
happening now if you really wanted to
see that occlusion what you could also
do is just get rid of the color and the
light calculation because it's not
really correct the way we're doing it
anyway so if we just didn't do this
color plus equals sphere color times
multiplier the only way we now get a
color is when the ray eventually hits
the sky because you can see that this is
the only moment inside this entire Loop
that we actually do anything with color
color starts as zero it only actually
gets a color based on the sky and it
gets multiplied with the multiplier
meaning the more bounce as it goes
through before it hits the sky the
darker that pixel will be so if I run
this you can see we get this result and
again the level of roughness here is
really going to determine the kind of
level of diffusion of the light and so
here because I have opted to five
bounces I'm getting this delicious
bouncing kind of between these two
spheres but then as I add like a little
bit of roughness here you can see what
happens to it all the way up to a
roughness of one where it's a very noisy
image but you can see we can clearly see
that kind of ambient occlusion taking
place okay let's go back to our previous
model
and there you go we're starting to get a
pretty nice looking image now I did
mention that today's episode will kind
of be about materials so let's talk a
little bit more about our current
material system why it's not very good
and what we can do to improve it well
the biggest problem with our material
system at the moment is the way we've
defined it is that each sphere actually
has like the material embedded in it the
way materials typically work is they're
completely disconnected from
objects from meshes now why is it set up
that way the reason being that we want
to be able to reuse materials like for
example I might want to apply the same
material to both of these spheres and
when I change the material I'd like both
spheres to change and if we just store
everything like as an instance inside
the sphere itself we obviously can't tie
one material to multiple objects and
that's definitely something we want to
be able to do so what we're going to do
instead is inside our scene we're going
to add a vector of materials and I'm
just going to call this materials what
this is going to let us do is just kind
of have this flat packed kind of array
dislike buffer of material data and then
every sphere is going to have a material
index instead of a material and we might
just set this to Zero by default we
might want to have like just the default
material in our scene kind of like how
in blender you just have like a default
material that is what your kind of mesh
will be rendered with unless you assign
one that could just be zero and that
could exist with are saying but
basically what this means is that we
kind of have the ability now to just
link one of these materials to a sphere
because we just have a material index
and this is also a side note exactly how
it's going to work when we dive into
like Vulcan RTX Ray tracing as well
we're going to have this huge buffer of
materials for every single object in our
scene and then in the shaders we'll be
able to just have a material index per
like primitive that we're Ray tracing
and look up that material from that
buffer to actually get those values so
this design is going to be the same but
again in this case really what this
enables us to do is just have one
material and have multiple spheres
multiple objects all using that single
material and so now that we've done this
if we go back here we'll have to change
a few things instead of looping over all
of the Spheres and displaying their
material values here what I'm going to
do is I'm going to cut all the material
values out I'm going to paste them over
here for now and then I'm going to have
to kind of go through a for Loop of
materials this time so we'll go through
all of the material else we'll copy all
of this push ID and separators probably
should just copy the entire for Loop and
then we'll go through and now that we're
going through the materials let's grab
this sphere but we'll replace this with
material
the Albedo here will be
material.albedo material dot roughness
and material.metallic what I might do is
since we're here let me just add a few
different parameters here so we'll add a
speed of 0.05 a minimum of zero we don't
want to go below zero and a maximum of
one we'll copy this and do the same for
the metallic over here and then up here
instead of having the material values
which we could do as well we could look
up the material displayed here but I'll
keep them separated for now we'll just
have a material index so this is going
to be a drag int we're going to call
this material and then that's just going
to be sphere.material index we'll set a
minimum or a speed of one sure a minute
because that's the default anyway a
minimum of zero and then a maximum of uh
the size of these materials now this
one's an INT so we'll make sure to cast
it to an end and here we have a maximum
of the size of materials by the way that
actually should be minus one because
that's the last index we're able to
actually set here and we obviously don't
want to Crash by going out of bounds
here so that is pretty much it for this
file if we go back to renderer though we
obviously have to look up the right
values so what we'll do is along with
retrieving the sphere we'll also
retrieve the sphere's material by just
looking at the Active scene materials
and then this will be once we have the
sphere we can just look at the material
index and that gets us all of our
material data which we can then use to
look up both the Albedo as well as the
roughness to see to what degree that Ray
should be scattered okay so that looks
pretty good back up in example layer
though one thing we have to do is
actually Define these materials in the
first place so we can do that just by
calling MSN materials in place back so
we're going to add a new material this
is going to add a new material into that
Vector but it also returns a reference
to that material so we might have our
kind of pink sphere material over here
and then I'll just duplicate that and
have a blue sphere material so this is
obviously going to be index 0 that's
going to be index one won't worry about
a default material for now and then
we'll just set the Albedo here to be the
same thing that we had over here and for
the blue sphere
we'll make it blue of course and let's
just copy that now a roughness let's go
ahead and set the pink sphere's
roughness to be uh zeros it's going to
be very reflective and then the blue
sphere's roughness will set to like 0.1
because I think that looked nice then we
just have to set the material index so
sphere dot material index is going to be
zero for our first sphere and then for
our second Sphere for the blue sphere is
going to be one and I think that's it
let's go ahead and hit F5 see what
happens all right beautiful so there you
go we have this image we have the kind
of reflection this is now with five
bounces and I mean it's still running
pretty decently 60 milliseconds per
frame on my laptop and this is of course
without any multi-threading at all just
on the CPU so yeah not too bad and of
course it does look a bit noisy but
that's because we're kind of generating
the image from scratch every frame what
we could do is just accumulate that
Randomness basically what I'm saying is
that when the light actually hits one of
those spheres and we determine some kind
of random Direction Why Don't we try
going a different random Direction every
frame and then just accumulating all the
results hey we've just discovered path
tracing and that of course we will get
to in the near future I'm very excited
trust me but yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button and
show your support for this series next
time we're going to take a bit of a
deeper look into lighting and diffuse
light and how we can actually simulate
that don't forget to check out brilliant
and brush up on your math and I will see
you guys next time goodbye
it's a great episode
[Music]